après l'histoire l'actualité la france
est à la veille d'une semaine sociale
troublée avec les différentes journées
d'action organisée par le syndicat cgt
mardi mercredi et la grève générale de
la fonction publique prévu par les
autres syndicats jeudi 20 octobre mais
le premier conflit qui domine est celui
des infirmiers et infirmières il
poursuivi visiblement le gouvernement et
la coordination des infirmières ne se
comprennent pas ou très mal
le premier ministre monsieur rocard
déclarait aujourd'hui dans une interview
au journal du dimanche
les infirmières n'ont sûrement pas
examiner à fond les propositions
d'augmentation qui leur ont été faites
et il ajoutait leur nom et sans doute un
refus du à l'énervement
réponse ce soir d'une des responsables
de la coordination interrogé par thierry
calmette
il semblerait que monsieur rocard nous
considèrons mis en pris une décision
d'énervement et face au rejet des
propositions de monsieur et 20 je crois
que nous avons toujours trouvé notre
sens aigu des responsabilités
il est vraiment dommage que monsieur
rocard nous prennent comme ça un petit
peu
la légère les malades depuis le début de
la grève ont toujours été soigné les
infirmières se sont toujours organisés
et ont toujours été responsable des
actes quelle honte quelle sont venus
près des malades
comment est ce que vous pouvez espérer
avoir quelque chose dans une négociation
alors que au départ où vous fixé tout de
suite 2000 francs et vous ne discutait
pas là dessus mais c'est pas vrai je
crois que les infirmières de base jeudi
qu'il n'a pas besoin d'être énarque pour
comprendre je veux dire le sens des
propositions qui ont été faites par
monsieur et 20 ce que nous réclamons
c'est un statut saint statut c'est le
droit et la reconnaissance de nos
compétences
1 il est évident que les infirmières de
base travail du jour et nuit dans les
hôpitaux qu'est le prennent en charge la
vie et la santé des malades et monsieur
rocard ne peut pas s'adresser à nous en
ces termes et comment est ce que vous
allez pouvoir arrêter un jour saluerait
apparemment drôle est parti dans une
impasse
non je crois que notre propos
aujourd'hui ce soir c'est nous nous
adressons solennellement à monsieur
rocard et nous lui demandons enfin de
pouvoir véritablement installée
instaurer un dialogue entre lui et nous
la coordination infirmières que nous
souhaitons c'est entre et entamer des
négociations ouvrir de riz de de
véritables négociations et ceci dans la
clarté et pas dans des fonds de couloir
comme cela s'est fait jusqu'à présent